Kim Kardashian gives fans a semi  not-safe-for-work glimpse at her latest  new juice her body really is the  accessory  [Music]  the reality star is the queen of  breaking the internet on Wednesday the  37 year old took to social media to  share this nearly naked pic from her  recent photo shoot where she posed in  the buff rocking body glitter and  nothing else I'm so curvy that if I try  to like put other things on and I look  like a joke the k'kaw Beauty founder  worked it for the camera Wow  wanting her famous curves in a few  behind-the-scenes videos posted to her  Instagram stories the shoot was for  Kim's beauty line which launches a  variety of ultra beams highlighters and  glosses on Friday perfect not so  coincidentally ultra light beam is the  title of the lead track on Kim's hubby  rapper Kanye West's most recent album  the life of Pablo when you're on the  ultra light beam this is a guy  cigar dream this is everything